I was encouraged encouraged by a very
positive feedback by my fellow ministers
on our green economy flagship initiated
in Bratislava we hope this budget Slava
green economic process will continue
with regular meetings the council
discussed conclusions on sustainable
water management I am very happy that
our focus on water has received so much
traction among member states now we need
to get our act together in the EU and
implement our international commitments
therefore I welcome the first debate
among ministers on effort sharing this
debate gave us important insights to
guide our future work on these crucial
initiatives finally by decisions take
taken today we have demonstrated our
commitment to a successful outcome of
the upcoming important international
meeting on biodiversity in Mexico the
main substantial achievements were
centered on three main areas first on
sustainable water management and
ministers adopted conclusions developed
under the guidance of the slovak
presidency and building on a conference
that Laszlo and myself opened together
in Bratislava last July the point that I
made to ministers today was that two
things will already go a very long way
to ensuring that this essential and
valuable resource is sustainably managed
first the full implementation of the
existing EU laws and secondly the
integration of sustainable water
approaches into other policy areas on
biodiversity we discussed the EU
position for the Cancun conference in
December which will bring together the
parties for the CBD 13 de Cartagena
protocol and where safety and the nagoya
protocol on access and benefit sharing
for the first time ministers
adopted conclusions today that will
enable us to speak with a clear and one
common line in Cancun I was struck by
the concern around the table that
targets and good intentions are not
enough and that we need to mobilize the
actors the policies and the resources to
deliver in practical terms